كما واصلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قصفها
الجويه والمدفعي لحي الشيخ رضوان شمالي
مدينه غزه بالتزامن مع اشتباكات ضاريه بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي خلال محاولات تقدم الياته في
الحي يعني تواصل الدبابات الاسرائيليه
التقدم في حي الشيخ رضوان وفي المنطقه
الشرقيه بالتحديد من هذا الحي حيث اقتحمت
الدبابات الاسرائيليه منطقه البركه ومنطقه
مسجد التقوى والمفترق ابو الام نزولا من
شارع الجلاء من من منطقه صيدليه ابن
الهيثم اشتباكات عنيفه وقصف مدفعي متواصل
على هذا الحي كما تستمعون المقاومه
الفلسطينيه استطاعت التصدي ل لهذه
الدبابات لكن الاشتباكات مستمره منذ
اللحظه التي تقدمت بها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بالاضافه الى ان قوات الاحتلال
شنت استهدافات بالطيران الحربي على على
عدد كبير من المنازل في هذا الحي وكما
انها حاصرت اربعه مدارس كانت تؤوي الاف
النازحين في هذا الحي اعتقلت عددا من
الرجال واطلقت سراح بعضهم بالاضافه الى
انهم انها تحاصر عددا من النساء داخل
المدارس وقد استطاعت بعض النساء الخروج
منها كما تشاهدون الان في هذه الخلفيه هذا
هو حي الشيخ
[موسيقى]
رضوان